In recent times,
the meetings between the U,
s presidents and European leaders,
they've become quite tense.
Did I say summit,
which took place in early July of 2018
has been pretty good proof of that since
it's up.
Some questions on the table is Donald
trump writes,
when criticizing his European partners,
all the European Nato countries taking
advantage of the United States saw me
and perhaps most importantly,
should Europe have an Ami.
Well,
this up,
if one thing has become very clear is
that Donald Trump isn't too fond of
these European leader meetings.
I mean how bothersome it is to have to
meet with all of these people.
I a poor old trump.
If they were at least as fun as Vladimir
Putin or Kin Jong,
I mean finning.
It'd be different.
Right?
It's an honor to be with you.
Thank you.
Is that the clash between the US
administration and most European
governments extends to virtually all
issues economy,
trade,
immigration and defense.
NATO members must finally contribute
their fair share and meet their
financial obligations,
but 23 of the 28 member nations are
still not paying what they should be
paying and what they're supposed to be
paying for their defense.
See,
the US president has been criticizing
NATO for years due to the alleged lack
of involvement of the European partners.
Spin back to the US president has been
saying things like that for almost 20
years.
It has no vital interest in Europe.
There are conflicts are not worth
American lives.
Pulling back from Europe would save this
country millions of dollars annually.
Donald trump in 2000.
Of course,
it isn't just about the tenants of the
White House.
The truth is that in recent decades,
the differences between Europe and
America have expanded,
for example,
of this baseball versus soccer and
appreciation for cars with gigantic
engines.
One can tell where the gas must be
cheaper,
right?
It's also the way in which weapons are
considered in all fields.
Even in defense,
the army and the military are very,
very important issues in us politics,
but over in Europe,
not so much and it's even worse than not
so much.
In fact,
these humps even frontpage issues and
they're certainly not very popular
prompts.
That's why since the Cold War ended,
the military spending of European
countries that belonged to NATO has
collapsed in terms of GDP ranging from
something a little over three percent to
less than one point five in Europe.
Military spending,
it just doesn't sell,
and this view is is greatly angered
Washington's politicians in recent years
and in this matter,
we're not only talking about Donald
Trump,
but also you,
Barack Obama and George W dot Bush,
their own visual politic.
In a previous video we told you why
isn't such a good idea for European
countries?
Do you spend more money on weapons,
but hold on just a minute.
What if Washington was actually right?
Now listen up.
If Washington was right,
here's a question for you,
and as I always say,
please don't google it because that's
cheating.
Do you know how many soldiers the
European NATO countries have in total?
Well,
they'll tell you it's approximately one
point 8 million soldiers.
However,
if this number only 30 percent can be
deployed in the case of a conflict and
only 50 to 100 thousands can be deployed
sustainably and for greater lengths of
time,
and folks in general,
the European armies,
they've got many operational problems.
Yup,
it's true.
They do spend a lot of money,
but their governments,
most of them don't really care very much
about the results.
We can.
For example,
look at Germany,
a country that in 2017 had a military
budget of approximately $45,000,000,000.
That is,
it has one of the top 10 largest
military budgets of any country.
Well,
despite being one of the countries with
the largest military budget a couple of
years ago,
a study by the consultancy firm Mckinsey
for revealed that almost 60 percent of
Germany's Eurofighter and Tornado
fighter aircrafts and 80 percent of
them,
most modern helicopters were not ready
for combat due to a lack of maintenance
updates and supplies.
At the end of 2017,
a parliamentary investigation showed
quite a similar results,
not one of the submarines and none of
the 14 main transport planes of the
German air force or even operational,
not a single one,
and we're not even exaggerating.
Even a document from the German Ministry
of Defense warns that the soldiers
didn't have enough protective vests when
to clothes or tents to participate in
any important NATO mission,
and believe me,
it's not just Germany.
For example,
during the war in Libya,
despite being a relatively small
conflicts,
just three weeks after the attacks
began,
the European air forces began to run out
of precision weapons and other words.
Governments spend large amounts of money
on weapons programs and they've had many
soldiers,
but that doesn't really matter when it
comes to the day to day operations.
And that's how we ended up with news
like this.
The Legion declares all out war on
obesity.
The elite unit of the Spanish infantry
launches a plan to combat obesity among
its members.
Honestly,
because that's not the worst of it.
Perhaps what annoys the US offices,
the most of the rules with which some of
the European armies have entered combat
under NATO.
For example,
in Afghanistan.
See many European governments don't want
to assume any kinds of risks,
so they ordered them military commanders
to maintain this soldiers away from the
front.
In the case of the Afghan campaign,
for example,
US soldiers sharing testimonies in which
they were denied medical evacuation by
Europeans because they were in a combat
zone,
wasn't strange.
Listen to this.
Ghana's Stan year 2008.
We were returning from a mission.
When a rocket hit the vehicle that was
in front of mine,
our Humvee was suddenly being attacked
by machine gunfire.
Of the 11 vehicles that entered the
ambush area for left inoperative and a
fifth one was destroyed over.
Boys had died and it doesn't.
We're wounded.
We were six hours away by car from our
base.
It was getting dark and the Taliban were
still attacking us.
When we call to ask for a medical
evacuation,
they asked us if the landing area was so
hot.
We said yes,
we were being attacked.
That moment of voice with a foreign
accent told me that their rules
prevented them from providing us
assistance.
He asked me if we could secure the
landing area or if we can move minutes
turned into hours and the Taliban
continued attacking us.
Then out of nowhere a voice came up on
the radio.
It was American.
A couple of Black Hawk helicopters from
a totally different mission had heard
our help call.
The pilots deviated immediately.
Within 15 minutes they landed in her
wounded were evacuated.
Our superiors told us that the NATO
country who is responsible for medical
evacuations had a rule that prevented
them from intervening,
instill hot areas.
We were furious.
Elliot Ackerman,
a veteran who served in the Afghanistan
Marine special operations core.
Just a second,
because this is really important in
Afghanistan alone,
nearly 900 European soldiers who have
lost their lives.
We're talking about political orders
that don't happen in all cases,
but which are very common.
I know it's not a matter of money.
It's a matter of commitment.
Every year the European NATO countries
spend almost $300,
billion dollars that is together.
They have the second largest military
budget after the United States.
It's
flight of this in Washington.
They want European NATO countries do
substantially increase the military
spending and that's where the magical
two percent of the GDP figures up here.
Yes,
the two percent milk
as he made very clear at the last NATO
summit,
Donald trump is furious.
According to the vast majority of the
countries of the Atlantic alliance,
they're late in their quota payments.
Check this out.
Many countries in NATO which we are
expected to defend or not only short of
their current commitment of two percent,
which is low,
but are also delinquent for many years
and payments that have not been made,
will they reimburse the US?
Well,
one of two is true.
Either he's saying this because he has
no idea or are you saying it because he
wants some electoral points.
Spa,
of course fooling the Veritas because
let's be clear,
this entire payments thing has no point
of reference.
Two percent is a military spending
objective from each country for its own
army that has nothing to do with NATO
payments or anything like that.
That is if a country spends less,
it doesn't own anything to NATO,
the United States or anyone else for
that matter.
The fact is that in 2014,
after a lot of pressure,
Barack Obama managed to get the European
NATO countries to commit to
substantially increasing the military
budget to reach two percent of their GDP
by 20,
24 and precisely due to that commitment.
Europe is the region of the world where
military spending is increasing the
most.
Check this out.
Awesome.
Yes.
You know that later,
trump and especially his supporters will
say that this was all thanks to him to
his magnificent negotiating skills.
However,
even if military spending increases,
it probably won't actually change
anything first.
This two percent figure it's a random
number which could be reached simply by
raising military salaries or cheating in
all kinds of other ways.
Greece,
for example,
is one of the few countries that
complies with this and it spends two
point three,
six percent of its GDP,
but a large part of that budget is used
to pay the military pensions and even
most of their investments in military
equipment is geared towards defense
against hockey,
which is another NATO member country as
a result of this.
Well,
even though the expenditure rule is
apparently being followed to the Greek
army brings little or nothing to the
organization's capabilities,
but even though all of this money could
be used to really improve the armies and
of course without political commitments,
it will never happen.
Not much will be achieved anyway.
European countries will continue to
depend on the United States for forced
deployments because each country on its
own wouldn't be able to afford to
maintain that kind of global
deployments.
Intelligence and supply capabilities and
of course given that in Europe,
military operations on popular,
neither the political commitments and
all the rules friends are in combat will
actually change.
That is we would have larger armies,
but at the moments of truth,
very similar deficiencies.
But also,
let's consider something else.
The armed forces can perform for
essential functions,
deterrents,
intervention in deployments,
occupation and cybersecurity for none of
these tasks as the current European
countries budgets a hindrance,
two point terrorism,
more quickly,
deploy somewhere in the world and face a
special situation.
You don't really need multiple aircraft
carriers.
That is redundant forces.
It's much more important to be able to
deploy quickly and manage a conflict.
For example,
there's the latest United States and
NATO wars in Afghanistan,
Iraq and Libya.
In all of them.
The military victory was simple,
but the postwar period,
it was an absolute disaster.
Preparing forces to manage local and
using the country's different
institutions to train the national
forces.
Not only the military but also from the
police trial courts,
prisons,
power plants,
etc.
Would probably have been a great deal
more useful at the end of the day.
VieW at facing of conflict requires a
lot of things and not always the same
ones.
The threats we face today don't require
re craft carriers or fighter bombers.
They require agility.
Europe doesn't need to spend more.
It spends a lot.
It just needs to spend better,
and that's where the idea of the
european army in that pascoe a european
army,
in december of 2017,
the european union launched the pascoe
program,
need permanent structured cooperation.
It's objective.
While that would be coordinating the
countries that participate in the
program in terms of security,
acquisition of war materials,
and joint defense in peace operations.
In other words,
to begin integrating the various armed
forces.
The program is still in a very incipient
phase and isn't considered the
equivalent of a european army yet,
however,
this could be the best solution to all
their problems.
The 25 countries that make up the
program by integrating that armies that
weapons purchases their training and
even by sharing resources could mean for
europe even while spending the last
would have a modern well equipped army
with great deployment capabilities.
After all,
if a country like Spain spends a fortune
buying leopard tanks,
which happens and in practice due to a
lack of means to deploy them,
they only uses them to defend against
Portugal.
They've made a totally unnecessary
expense.
Wouldn't you agree,
folks today?
The risks and challenges,
they're global,
so I sincerely belieVe that europe needs
more integration to do you think is data
and seek to complete to the us.
Military has contributions within the
nato framework,
but it's not achieved by spending more
also almost $300,000,000,000
a year.
It should be more than enough,
but now it's your sound.
Do you think europe should develop its
own army?
Well,
believe your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
Don't forget to check it off.
Friends and reconsider media podcast as
well.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
that one on.
Also.
Of course,
this channel is made possible because of
patron and our patrons on that platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political
coverage,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.